and the first thing somebody did can I
talk about porn yes yes you can
[Music]
hey everybody today we're at BuzzFeed a
Rebecca Black is here she's gonna let
all the Twitter followers decide what
she does here at BuzzFeed so we're gonna
start out by changing our appearance you
know we want to look nice we need to be
camera-ready
I am at BuzzFeed video today and I'm
letting you decide my whole day first up
how should keep Hobbs and I change our
appearance glitter concealer magnetic
fauna for ice water hot yeah I did it
wait is it okay I know I said wait at
the last moment but I was right I really
shouldn't know well Rebecca look what
they chose I'm so excited you know what
this means right that we put on
concealer and then glitter right yeah
are we not allowed to do this with
mirrors so first you put it you want to
do in that diamond shape
oh is this sponge supposed to be wet
yeah okay wait for that I need you to
blend a little bit I'm doing you a favor
okay come on if you've never grabbed
anyone by the nose before so let's let's
talk you you had a song called the
greatest song yes so that came out it's
been really fun and justice last week it
hit the top 50 on the book or dance
chart oh that's great that's huge
I also aspire to be on a chart we can
get you there done I love it you look
great but looking great in reality is
one thing what about virtual reality
never experienced it you've never done
bursar reality actually that's a lie can
I talk about porn I was at a white
elephant party this last Christmas and
someone bought a virtual reality thing
they could go up the goggles right sure
okay red build-up weird gross like yo
yeah it was yeah alright Rebecca we're
gonna do some PR of our own today but no
dicks will be involved so much desire
plan I have three
you're gonna set out on you're gonna set
that on your Twitter should we do VR
painting VR fighting or a VR nightmare
all right Rebecca the internet shows VR
nightmare so I'm gonna start a game
called the cubicle just work what am i
doing look around
what do you see a printer but put it in
the file put it in the file cabinet oh
it didn't like that so there's a
calendar mm-hmm
hey what does it say oh my god we just
have it in the calendar wait what's
happening what's happening where am I
going
oh wait oh my god I feel like I'm
actually in the in like an elevator well
I guess I'll just be here with my files
what is that I gotta keep working
can i but what about these big files
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god would they
do this
all my work to put them back in wait
wait now - oh no where am I
oh my god did I just die yeah are we
back yeah it's so dramatic not prepared
to be back here I want to go back I
don't know I forgot that we were filming
a video let's keep on with the video huh
don't get too hung up on your emotional
distress and even though my followers
did that to me why don't you send that
out to your Twitter you can let them
choose between trying weird gum watching
extraction videos or watching videos of
animals giving birth
care about that - I'm just preparing
myself mentally oh he's got a lot of got
a lot of samples he does have a lot of
pimples
well glad we experienced that together
that was gross
next up let's make some music we could
write a song about Thursday sing happy
birthday to a stranger or since flash
narrates people's lives five minutes on
the pole sent it out
[Music]
nothing ever happens on Thursday and a
full day of the week
nothing ever happens on Thursday at
least nothing ever happens to me
Saturdays and Sundays are Party days and
that stays and such days and the wrong
way and of a new day sweet but nothing
[Music]
just throwing back
[Music]
oh god it's time for you to go now no
it's sex but it means it's our most
exciting poll this is true the last boy
you're gonna send out is how the video
should end should it end with me dying
in your arms us waking up and it was all
a dream or should it be a Blair Witch
ending her to Nadal Rebecca
I heard everybody go
[Music]
[Applause]
that's very fun you know watching me and
Rebecca hanging out guy just feels a
little void in your life and every new
you need filled you know yeah and when
you need to fill that void again you can
just watch the episodes quadrotors comes
out March I mean Rebecca team-up
you